what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite football players pause the
season halfway through to go to the
world's biggest football tournament
Players stop being polite and start
getting heated this is the champions of
the world this is it Leo our last chance
to win the World Cup you mean my last
chance to win the World Cup yours was in
2018. we're here to put engeland on top
of the map do you mean on the map like
on the map of England behind you that's
England is that what a map looks like
and why are you here I just genuinely
love this country and their vibrant
football culture
hello I'd just like to take this
opportunity to remind everyone about the
Champions League
[Music]
[Music]
with England in our group this is going
to be exactly like the American
Revolution which we just learned about
in a documentary on the plane ride over
here we're back in the world cup and
this time we are going all the way
hopefully to the quarterfinal
[Music]
well if it isn't my old friends from
Ghana haven't seen you guys since 2010
no hard feelings right yeah let me give
you a hand gentlemen how are my favorite
cash cows I mean players was the flight
nice I don't care here let me put you
towards your accommodations it's all
behind you isn't it oh this mansion no
no no this is for our corporate sponsors
your Mansion is over there
it's tiny but when you consider we built
it in one night and it's actually very
impressive whoa I'd love to know how you
pulled that off someone should do some
long-form investigative journalism about
that absolutely not anyways you're gonna
love it there every group gets their own
room wait we have to share
dude the corporate sponsors have to
share of course not
[Music]
at the moment
well then we came with terrible kids but
we'll be leaving with the World Cup here
here
it's all the generation let's go yeah
all right
these Americans are quite confident for
a team whose Captain rides the bench at
his Club
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
clean sheetus no Morris give it it's not
funny
you dude who puts vinegar on their fries
they're called chips and you're one to
talk who drinks like that it's called a
cake stand bro it's a form of art
so what's it like being stuck with the
English and the Americans honestly we're
just happy to be here attention
could be
we divvy up the room whoa whoa whoa are
you gonna tell us what we can and can't
do in our section like you do back home
dividing up territory that doesn't
belong to you is not cool yeah bro
maybe I can help I've been embedded
amongst the Americans for some time now
and have managed to pick up a bit of
their language
sup fam No Cap I'm him please good luck
getting through to them they use
Fahrenheit actually your teams are more
common than you think you're both full
of exciting young talent but your
women's teams are way better and much
more likable neither of you is going to
win the World Cup and frankly you're
both a bit annoying don't be ridiculous
everyone loves English football no
everybody loves the Premier League you
guys not so much you weren't even
invited to the favorites party uh
favorites party yeah Brazil always
throws a big party for all the
tournament favorites England has been to
many major tournaments and I've never
heard of a favorite party
awkward
[Music]
you can do it Neymar so more than you
break it
[Music]
oh
oh
so uh how's Europa League [ __ ] you
ass party and didn't invite us wait why
is Canada here
hey man Canada's cool
wow what a harsh L to take this was
supposed to be an American Revolution
but it feels like a Great Depression we
don't want to make your stupid body
anyway and you smell safe it's wrong
there's supposed to be a you holy [ __ ]
we are annoying
[Music]
can't get enough of the champions
talk show turn into Champions chat on
December 2nd but I'll be covering the
world's biggest football tournament you
won't want to miss this the way Egypt
Miss qualifications oh no the lasers are
back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]